i want to get to our daily cancellation
i will be canceling
with great wrath and vengeance some of
the people involved
in this story watch a lot of dads might
say they do the same thing as ishmael
casillas did
when he found a grown man inside his 14
year old daughter's bedroom
and that is to beat that man bloody even
knocked out some teeth
but investigators say there's only so
much georgia law allows
and they say the dad crossed the line
that's forty one-year-old ismail cassius
on the left and twenty-year-old
kiwantrezes humphreys on the right
investigators say the two men first met
early july fourth morning
in the bedroom of cassius's
fourteen-year-old daughter
investigators say in a rage the dad
severely beat
and choked humphries even chipped and
knocked out some teeth
and if it had stopped there
investigators say the dad might not be
facing any charges
but they say ishmael casillas asked his
wife for a gun and they say after the 20
year old jumped out the bedroom window
the dad met him in the front yard and
continued the beating threatening his
life
and firing shots through the
neighborhood as the young man ran away
investigators say that is where casillas
crossed the line
there's a line that you know he can't
cross
we can't cross there's a stopping point
when somebody's no longer a threat to
you
my advice would be let it go and contact
us and let us
handle it don't take it into your own
hands investigators have also charged
kiwantreze's humphreys with child
molestation
they say he was in a relationship with
the 14 year old girl and climbed
through her bedroom window investigators
say humphries is known as
man man because of his age and the girls
they are pursuing a sex crime
investigation and more charges are
possible
we've gathered phone evidence from the
from the young lady
the young man's phone has been looked at
and those are things that we're still
looking into as to
possibly further further charges
the dad was taken into custody that
morning on july 4th
they say after identifying and locating
manman humphries
he was taken into custody in putnam
county thursday night
okay now i hope it's already obvious to
you that i'm not canceling the father
here
i i would build a statue to him if i
could i would build a statue
electrify it cover it in barbed wire
maybe put
trap doors around the base of it so that
if you get too close you'll fall into a
pit of alligators
that's actually what i would like to do
with all statues if i was under my
regime that's all we'll be doing
but he is not cancelled i am i'm
cancelling
obviously the child molesting scumbag
that goes without saying
uh let's take a look at him again after
the beating that's what he looks like
so that's that's just a wonderful
heartwarming picture right there
um but also i'm canceling the local
authorities
for pressing charges now let's think
about this for a moment put yourself
in ishmael's shoes here the father
a man climbed into your window to molest
your daughter your adolescent
daughter you find her find him in her
room
i submit that there is essentially
nothing you can do in that scenario
that should land you in prison i mean
you would have to go
very very very far and get very creative
in your response to that situation to
justify criminal charges
if they could be justified at all on any
level whatsoever
um this loving father did not go
overboard in the slightest bit he
whooped the guy's ass
of course any father worth a damn would
do that that's just
standard operating procedure you have to
do that
the only bit the only sort of extra bit
of relish that he put on this particular
hot dog
was to tell his wife to go get the gun
which i love that by the way he told his
wife
i've always wanted to say how do you get
the shotgun i've always wanted to say
that
um and he said that to his wife and then
he fired some shots as the guy runs away
okay now the way that i read that and
hear that it seems like there were more
warning shots
than anything i believe the report said
that he fired the shots as the guy read
didn't even say that he fired them at
him
um so it seems more like warning shots
of
hey this is what's going to happen if
you come back again type of thing
but either way listen this is a man who
broke into your home
to molest your daughter you don't know
if he has a gun on him
you don't know if he has a gun back at
his car um
if he stashed a gun outside you don't
know he might circle back and try to
hurt your daughter try to hurt you
you are perfectly justified as far as i
could tell in treating him as a lethal
threat
even as he runs away because he might
not really be running away
he's just running you don't know if he's
going away he's going to come back if
he's going to run around back
going to get a weapon i i think you're
justified in assuming
that he is a lethal threat the entire
time he's within your sights
as far as i'm concerned at least
those are the arguments that i would
accept
if i was on the jury um
i don't even know if what i'm saying is
legally valid by georgia state law
probably isn't
i don't care if i'm on that jury
the dad's lawyer could just offer that
as a defense and i'm going to quit or he
could say that
you know he was temporarily insane with
anger
i'd accept that he could say he tripped
and fell and accidentally fired the gun
i'd accept that argument too um he could
say that he thought the gun was a laser
tag gun
you know and i i would also you know he
thought he was playing laser tag
i'd i'd take that defense that would be
convincing to me
or his entire defense could be your
honor
look uh listen
come on you know you understand
come on that could be his entire defense
i personally on the jury would find that
argument
probably most of all deeply compelling
and convincing
or literally any other argument at all
the point is that
if you break into a man's house to
molest his daughter you have just
volunteered yourself for some very
unpleasant treatment um you have
consented to it even if not
verbally you as the saying goes have
written a check
that your ass will now have to cash
so i say cheers to that great father for
doing his job
um this country would be in pretty good
shape if there were like 50 million more
dads
like that out there we were just talking
about we started the show talking about
the
importance of having dads in the home
well here's one of the reasons
protector of the family so i would uh
cheers to him and uh a a stern
cancellation to everyone involved
with arresting and charging him i i just
have to believe
especially in georgia there's just i i
have to believe there's no jury
i'd have to believe there's no jury in
america much less in georgia that we can
victim that is my hope and prayer
thank you for tuning into the daily wire
one of the fastest growing conservative
media outlets in the entire country if
you enjoyed this video
uh be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content